tyler malley as you detailed in the open
lark he has owned the pirates in 2021
kyle farmer just a touch laid hayes can
fly
and he beats it out
and they are going to take a look
what do you got
out
and it is out
and the pirates have two on with one out
[Music]
and he gets his first strikeout moran
down swinging
swing in the miss he struck him out
consecutive case for mali and he strands
a couple of walks second straight start
against these reds for keller looking
for his first win against these reds and
six career starts
off parks glove
professional hitter matt schrock
good work keller to get castellanos
strikes out a bunch good time to get one
and he'll face fodo now
he swings and pops it up
in the infield perez back behind home
plate and he makes the catch and that
ends the inning
three straight strikeouts for mellon
that's four straight
mali strikeouts
there to cover five in a row retired by
tyler mallett
kyle farmer through the right side this
guy has just been so good for this team
[Music]
against the shift hey eugenio suarez
farmer through second he'll claim third
back-to-back hits first pitch swinging
tucker barnhart shift on
sharp grab ball to second
flip to tucker
farmer scores
no rbi reds on the board one to nothing
three
five strikeouts for valley
friedel
showing off some speed
one nothing reds
[Music]
what's this one deep to right gavel on
his horse that's over his head whacks
off the wall and right and mally trying
for two gamble's throw is right there
what a play by ben gamel
cole tucker applies the tag
camel played it perfectly off the wall
malley is retired
there's a swing and a fly ball out to
short right field
park the second baseman is there gamble
behind him just in case catches made and
the inning ends
swing
and a miss only a piece that's six k's
for tyler malley see if ben gamble
hasn't measured tyler malley struck him
out in the first
fly ball to right
nearing the wall castiano's back
and clear the deck cannonball coming
ben camel ties it at one his eighth
definitely didn't get all of it actually
sounded weird off the bat sounded like
uh it jammed him you guys ready for this
this is the bat that ben gamble just
homer with
a broken bat home run
2-2
tucker will get it
bamo jogs up to second two walks in a
single and the reds have them loaded big
spot for t.j friedl
in the air to left
alford measures it up
bottle tags at third
throw in they can see the run bottle
sprints across the plate sac fly rbi for
the rookie tj friedl and the reds have
the lead back to the one mark at second
top of the order key brian hayes
and into center field a base hit runner
gonna be waived
and the throw to the plate is gonna be
late keep ryan hayes will go into second
and it's tied at two one oh to tucker
oh laced into center field they've got
another run over and here comes key
brian hayes
gold tucker
gives the pirates the lead
bouncing ball haze there is one there is
two mitch keller
outstanding work tonight
swing of the miss boy park done on
strikes
there's that chris pop
back-to-back case for wilson that ain't
no great
kyle farmer number 201 he is three for
three and a one-out runner
that is through the shift base hit
farmer through second scoop by gavilan
wright lobs towards second farmer claims
third then in the quarters las roma
cabrera is going to hit for friedel
and panda does get out of it
96 blew it by him upstairs back-to-back
walks from meers
tying rounded scoring position
[Applause]
shallow center tucker sprinting out
we'll get there
stop sign to shields fire from center by
reynolds a good throw and a wise hold
but schrock bloops one in and they're
loaded with nobody out
a pop-up and moran with room oh that's
just how about that just as good as a
strikeout
popped it up well he did
[Applause]
it's reynolds to make the catch
and a big second out
and all eyes on kyle farmer here's the
pitch he could go break the ball and he
fooled him strike three call
what a job by nick mears
see if perez can make lorenzen pay for
these mistakes walking two hitters
here's the 01 and the swing of the ball
hammered to the right field corner this
one's going to head to the wall gammel
touches third he's on his way home and
will score alford stays at third it's an
rbi single by michael perez and the
pirates lead 4-2
[Music]
and lifted the left plenty deep for the
speedy alford to give the pirates
another run make it 5-2
well done hoy park
and here is yoshitsugo
line drive right field
suits still go into the corner
perez will score
suits sugo into second base
with a pinch hit rbi double pirates
leading at 6-2
3-2
and he struck him out
struck him out looking
chasing tree of a scoreless bottom of
the eighth chris stratton who returns to
the mound after suffering that lone save
on sunday in miami stratton sets and
delivers and a swing of the fly ball to
center reynolds is there he makes the
catch the ball game is over and the
pirates even the series
they beat the reds tonight 6-2